le problème des lunettes sait aussi que
ça fait des gros reflet donc en les
enlève salue aujourd'hui je fais la
vidéo depuis toulon puisque je suis
toujours sur la tournée de mental rodage
ça fait longtemps que j'ai pas parlé des
forçage psychologique sur la chaîne donc
on va faire ça c'est parti
[Musique]
alors un forçage psychologique c'est le
fait de forcer quelqu'un à faire un
choix le choix qu'on veut nous dans les
vidéos de l'année dernière quand je
faisais une vidéo par jour on a déjà
abordé plusieurs fois ce sujet j'ai même
d'ailleurs une vidéo qui doit traîner
sur la chaîne d'avant que je lance
vraiment la chaîne je vous mettre une
petite fiche par là vous allez pouvoir y
accéder
c'en est un alors là forcément si vous
allez le faire en étant prévenu ça va
moins fonctionné et est ce que vous êtes
prévenus donc forcément moins
intensément tu fais attention à ce que
tu sais que je vais te forcer vous vous
comprenez principe je me suis pas
approché trop près encore de cette
caméra bref quelle plein de technique
déjà pour influencer des choix déjà la
technique de la liberté on en avait
parlé ensemble je vous avais déjà dit
que vous êtes libre de ne pas vous
abonner à la chaîne c'est pas un souci
vous faites ce que vous voulez c'est
pareil vous êtes libre de ne pas mettre
un pouce en l'air c'est vous qui voyez
c'est pas une obligation quoi c'est
vraiment votre liberté avoue donc ça
c'est plutôt une technique d' influence
un forçage psychologique c'est plus que
de l' influence et là je prends un
forçage des hivernants liverman qui
était un grand magicien qui était
considéré comme un maître magicien que
j'ai longtemps hésité à vous parler de
cette technique puisqu'elle appartient
au patrimoine magique et en me
renseignant dans ses normes et mende
ouvrage je me suis aperçue qu'elle
appartenait aux savoirs en général d'un
tour de magie ne peut pas reposer dessus
et que son explication est intéressante
dans le fonctionnement de notre
comportement le but de ce voyage
psychologique et de faire choisir à une
personne un objet parmi quatre objets
identiques les mêmes sinon ça ne
fonctionne pas où ça fonctionne beaucoup
moins bien vous devez mettre ces quatre
objets entre la personne et vous un
petit peu comme un chemin je reprécise
encore une fois les quatre objets sont
identiques et doivent avoir à peu près
le même espace qui les sépare et vous
demander à la personne en face de vous
de choisir l'un des quatre donc de le
prendre physiquement de le choisir et le
mot choisir est important parce que ça
veut dire qu'il ya une petite réflexion
qui va se faire donc vous devez la
presser en terme de timing mais elle
doit réellement choisir c'est là on voit
le poids des mots sur nos prises de
décisions si je dis juste à une personne
vas-y prend un objet d' a tout de suite
elle va prendre un objet donc peut-être
le premier qui virent si je lui dis
choisi un objet ça veut dire qu'il ya un
petit processus conscient ou inconscient
qui va se faire à l'intérieur avec un
procédé de sélection et ça c'est
intéressant
et pourquoi c'est intéressant je vais
vous le dire pour que c'est intéressant
c'est intéressant parce que la personne
qui est situé ici va de base éliminés
ou du moins avoir tendance à éliminer
les extrémités celle ci est celle ci
puisque les extrémités ont l'air
vraiment différente parce que c'est
quelque chose de remarquable donc dans
le choix on se dit bah non c'est trop
évident une extrémité bonne année à
beaune et vous c'est un prince t4 cuir
et je me suis permis de couper le son
tiens su comment vous donc les
extrémités c'est trop évident ça paraît
trop évident à notre cerveau et ensuite
quand on choisit quelque chose dans
l'impression de trop moins évident dans
notre choix si on va chercher loin dans
la majeure partie des cas j'ai plein de
statistiques j'ai lu plein de stade je
veux pas vous les données puisque il y
en a aucune qui a été validé par un
espèce de protocole qui nous permet
d'affirmer que c'est ce chiffre au lie
pas un autre mais on va dire de la
majorité des cas c'est celle ci qui va
être sélectionné je sais pas si quand je
vous ai fait la démonstration date à
l'heure vous aviez eu que cette tendance
là je pas sûr que ça marche bien en
vidéo néanmoins ce qui est à retenir
s'écrit aussi quatre objets identiques
sont placés tel un chemin entre deux
personnes avec un écart équivalent qu'on
demande à la personne en face de choisir
un objet la personne va choisir le
troisième objet en partant d'elle pas
les extrémités pas le deuxième et le
troisième
vous pouvez vous amuser à faire ça c'est
assez intéressant de le constater et
depuis 2006 que j'ai eu connaissance de
ça j'ai eu le temps de les prouver
maintes et maintes fois et s'avère que
ça c'est très rarement avéré
différemment alors moi j'ai monté un
petit quelque chose qui me permettait de
pouvoir l'essayer en faisant un tour
sans viande et que vous dire ce que je
faisais moi c'est une idée à moi donc
vous en faites bien ce que vous voulez
je le mettais dans une enveloppe un bout
de carton d'un côté de ce bout de carton
il y avait marqué retourne la cuillère
que tu as choisie et d'un autre carton
il ya et marquer tu choisiras la
troisième cuillère en partant de toi si
c'était des cuillères parce que sinon ça
ne fonctionne pas avec vous et je
reconnais évidemment de quel côté du
carton été marqués telle ou telle chose
bref je mettais le carton dans l'
enveloppe et je pose l enveloppe à un
petit pain au chocolat alors tim pains
au chocolat ou team chocolatines dites
le moi dans les commentaires ça si tu
sais que ça fout le bordel c'est un pan
chocolat chocolatines mon gars je vous
propose est donc à la personne de
choisir une cuillère sauf que dans la
deuxième cuillère en partant de la
personne c'est à dire celle ci au dos je
faisais une croix où je m'étais hockey
où je m'étais merci
si j'avais un petit charpy qui écrivait
de manière fine mais que l'objet était
assez gros comme une carte à jouer par
exemple ce qui fait que je demandais de
choisir une cuillère la personne n'a
jamais pris ni la première ni la
quatrième ça à chaque fois il ya jamais
eu de souci avec ces la plupart du temps
elles prenaient celle ci ce qui
permettait d'avoir le carton on sortait
dans le bon sens de l' enveloppe et y
avait marqué merci de chose d'avoir
choisi le le troisième objet la soirée
était la troisième cuillère et si jamais
c'était la deuxième dans les rares cas
où c'était celle ci et que du coup ça
avait raté je retourne l enveloppe je
sors thème carton donc là du coup le
côté visible du carton c'était retourne
l'objet la personne retourner l'objet il
y avait une croix ou merci ou ok je
disais tu sais que c'est là parce qu'il
n'y avait pas le choix
effectivement la personne ne pouvait
retourner les autres objets il n'y avait
rien d'autre guérir voilà ça c'est une
petite astuce si vous voulez essayer en
minimisant le risque de vous tromper
vous pouvez faire ça je range les
cuillères temps que je vous parle ça
vous permet de pouvoir essayer de
pouvoir voir les possibilités et de
pouvoir constater le mécanisme de choix
comment fonctionne notre cerveau quand
on doit faire un processus de choix
comme ça on est du coût prévisible dans
notre choix vous savez pour une
prochaine vidéo qui va sortir ce mois-ci
je vais faire une vidéo avec entre 25 et
50 abonnés d'autres d'entre vous qui
regardez cette vidéo là c'est une vidéo
qui va se passer par skype donc je vais
rencontrer beaucoup beaucoup de
personnes par skype ou en physique s'il
ya des gens sur paris peut-être c'est
possible et je vais faire un tirage au
sort pour ça je vais pas faire le tirage
au sort sur la chaîne youtube c'est pas
très pratique je le faire sur facebook
sur la fanpage facebook fabien olicard
avec un petit rat côté vous avez le lien
tout derrière dans la description si
vous voulez faire partie du truc vous
allez voir directement sur la page et un
commentaire où je vous parle de ça et
vous mettez un petit commentaire en
disant je veux bien participer et vous
ferez partie du tirage au sort alors
comme d'habitude vous pouvez cliquer ou
vous abonner et rendez vous très bientôt
ciao
[Musique]